wie kann denn ein nein ein schaden für
die demokratie sein
die frage ist ja wer dieses nein möchte
er sich durchs lässt der politische
wille der rechtsradikalen aktivitäten
gesetzt und das mit hilfe der cdu in
sachsen anhalt und das finde ich es
schon ein schaden für die demokratie
wenn man kann doch nicht nur weil die
afb gegen die gebührenerhöhung ist jetzt
allen deutschen sagen ihr müsst auf
jeden fall mehr gebühren höhere gebühren
zahlen nur damit wir nicht derselben
meinung sind wie die afd
das ist nicht der punkt aber erstens
wissen sie wahrscheinlich dass die fdp
nicht nur gegen die gebührenerhöhung ist
und generell ein gegner der freien
presse ist die ideale stöße und mit
unseren kunden an dem punkt dass er
jetzt nichts am hut hat und zweitens ist
es ja eine feststellung einer
unabhängigen institution die genau dafür
da ist festzustellen dass ihr team
brauchen das ist geschehen und 15 länder
sind ja die 15 spd regierte länder rider
sondern sind ja viele die von der cdu
regiert den von grünen und anderen
linkspartei anderen parteien
und wenn 15 min der platz war zu stimmen
auch mit der cdu
und das in sachsen anhalt nur deswegen
nicht geschieht weil die afg das nicht
will man ja eigentlich gar nicht nutzt
im landtag dann muss ich sagen ist das
wirklich schon schaden für die
meinungsfreiheit aber ist es so schlau
den die insgesamt das system in frage
stellen die insgesamt von lügen presse
brüllen usw ist es so schlau denen die
kritik an ard und zdf zu überlassen wäre
es nicht viel schlauer gewesen
man würde selber also auch cdu und spd
mal ganz genau hingucken wofür die acht
milliarden euro genutzt werden und ob
diese gebührenerhöhung wirklich
notwendig ist in corona zeiten ihre
frage ist ja keine frage ist also
unterstellung erstens beschäftigen sich
die sp die symbole von anfang an der
bild -zeitung darf man jeden dessen
jahren meinung
dagegen behaupten und zwar hat die
kommission diese kef die dafür da ist
vorgesehen ja keineswegs die forderungen
akzeptiert die haben wollten sahen die
hat das festgestellt dass aus ihrer
sicht objektiv notwendig ist und dem
haben sich 15 länder angeschlossen und
einsicht in das land nur aus dem grund
nicht weil man cdu näher an der meinung
der rechtsradikalen dort ist als an die
hinter demokratischen koalitionspartner
und das ist ein problem und das sehen
wir nicht nur bei diesem thema ist
überhaupt waren die sektkorken haben die
knallten auf die fraktionen in magdeburg
nirgendwo sonst und das uns mal klar
feststellen das ist eine niederlage für
die demokratie
und darüber sollte sich niemand freuen
auch nicht die konkurrenz stehen zu
öffnen
vielen dank ralf stegner ich sehe es ein
bisschen anders ich finde das nein muss
zur demokratie gehören selbst wenn die
ard mal mehr oder weniger zufällig
derselben meinung ist ich dann gehen für
das interview sie dürfen uns kritisieren
wir dürfen sie kritisieren wir alle
gemeinsam dürfen die
öffentlich-rechtlichen kritisieren und
wir dürfen um so mehr die afg
kritisieren danke ralf stegner